david pollock and the college gameday
crew will be live from tuscaloosa this
weekend at 9 00
a.m on espn let me start with the role
of the head coach with nick saban not
there david
um how important is it having your head
coach there the role that he plays on
game day as opposed to what happens
during the week
not every head coach is made the same um
first of all which is which is
important to know but nick saban is he
is mr detail
everything runs through nick saban like
coin toss dan
who's going out there which side they're
gonna defend
two-point plays by the way warm-ups he's
looking at kickers on the hash like
he's he made it from x he ran this play
from there i mean
he's literally as involved as any coach
in all of college football so
to answer your poll question i literally
would put nick saban
at the top of that list so them not
having that and that's not that's just
from a schematic standpoint right
i'm not even talking about from a
motivation standpoint you've seen him
get after his guys and his guys know
like you better show up
and you better do your job now you know
dad's not over your shoulder over there
looking at you
it allows you to relax a little bit
maybe not play
as energetic and maybe not be as tense
and by the way he also puts his
coaches on notice all those dudes know
they better bring it too so this is a
huge loss man it's not just a game
manager this isn't bobby bowden that
oversaw everything late in his career or
joe paul this is a guy that's
everything in that building goes through
nick saban
you imagine saban at home during this
game
dude no way no he ain't gonna be at home
by the way
i'm telling you we need to have a
contest whoever finds him in the stadium
in the box on the sidelines like
the fine nick saban game he's he's so
he's so controlling and he's got his
hand on everything i just can't and the
rules stipulate by the way that
he can't have any communication with him
so he can't go back and forth
um now listen it doesn't say anything
about text message but
he can't he can't have a phone
conversation and have
a direct line or direct contact and i i
don't see it happening dan
he's gonna find a way to make that
happen do you think he's going to be in
communication
with somebody on the sidelines during
the game yes i i think
listen it doesn't say anything about
text message in the bylaws so i think he
can text but
um you know i still think it's think
about this game and how it was decided
the last two times georgia faced alabama
alabama put in backup quarterbacks nick
saban had to make that call on the
sidelines
you got to look in people's eyes and
make that call so yeah he's going to
have to have more trust than he ever has
um sarkeesian obviously he's ah has been
a head coach in the past so
he's kind of got some experience but i
think nick will find a way to make sure
that he's got his hands on everything
and he's
he's making calls and he's trying to put
his team in the best position to succeed
but
i think it's going to be difficult
because the rules state you can't but
it's the sec i mean the rules are kind
of optional down south bro
and speaking from experience having
played in the sec
hundred percent rules don't always apply
i mean
it's not you know it's not always it's
not always a game
but if georgia's gonna get him this is
like you're running out of excuses here
david
yeah but you know what though here's the
thing even if georgia wins you know
nick's nick's assistant he's he's
undefeated against all of his assistants
does this count like nick wasn't there
so it really
doesn't matter you know it's interesting
too for the playoff picture dan because
this game really doesn't matter as long
as this is a close game
and neither team gets boat raced you're
still
very much in the playoff picture you're
still you still got a rematch in
december probably the way things are
looking where
you can go at it again and and both
those teams will be alive but
um no if george if you're a georgia fan
you're like all right well how much
i had georgia fans obviously i went to
university of georgia fans texted me
well wait a minute
he was close to his defense all weekend
do we need to quarantine them
so i think if you're georgia you're
definitely like wait a minute if it's
gonna happen this has to be the year
well also i think we have to keep an eye
out on more positive tests at alabama
because
coach saban's one of those i'm on the
field i'm involved with the players here
and with other coaches
so i i don't know if they're tested
today
how many times are you tested you know
during the course of a week during the
season
every school is different but alabama's
testing every day okay so
and so here's the thing by the way
they're the only two you know the ad and
nick saban are the two that tested
positive no players
um but it could be a false positive what
if it comes back today
and and it's not positive and and we
just had 24 hours of madness and
craziness and and
now nick's going to be back at practice
and things could be back to normal so
the more here's the thing if you're not
uh
like all coaches across college football
dan they read nick saban's books
and they read all these books of these
coaches and how they think and formulate
well this year isn't about that this
year you better be able to adapt you
better be able to improvise you better
be able to come up with some stuff on
the fly on your own
you better be practicing people at
multiple positions and you better have
plans for when coaches aren't there i
mean
you saw it with mike norvell from
florida state he didn't get to coach the
game you saw
virginia tech's defensive coordinator
last two weeks didn't get to be at the
game
you better be able to adapt and
improvise this year more than ever
he's david pollock former nfl player and
uh
when are you going into the college
football hall of fame
well it was it was supposed to be this
year but they're not doing the uh the
induction ceremony because of all the
stuff that's going on so i think
next year they'll um if they as they ran
out of people to put in so they're going
to put me in next year no
stop it what are you benching these days
can you bench more than fowler 100
yes come on bro i don't know i better be
able to
listen i know fowler swole but i mean i
if i can't bench more than fowler i i
think i would have problems but
i don't throw around the heavyweight
anymore dan i don't need that stuff
anymore i'm more of a reps guy
we're done with that fowler is filling
the sleeves man
he's he's strong he's stout he's always
taking pride in that you know he's got
to look good in that suit man he's got
to fill that puppy out
is north carolina for real
[Music]
well i mean you watch their offense and
you go yeah they just dropped 50 on
virginia tech even though half of
virginia tech's defense wasn't there
um but their defense gave up 40. so i i
think they're
i think they're a team that is they
found their quarterback they got a lot
of skill
they've got a really good offense but
they're not a team that's recruited in
an elite level for a bunch of years so
they're really good but they're i don't
think they're on the level of clemson's
and these playoff teams that have been
recruiting at a high level for a long
time but they don't play clemson this
year
well they might play in the acc
championship game but they got notre
dame
they got notre dame listen notre dame's
in a position where notre dame's
recruited better and been
um better for longer so i think notre
dame's a team that could obviously get
them too but i'm interested to see the
acc with
notre dame and we say you know what
clemson did last week right miami's like
hey
miami's coming miami's coming clemson's
like shut up sit down
like we're not ready to hear from you so
it's going to be interesting hopefully
notre dame will give
you know clemson a game and we'll start
to see them get challenged at some point
because right now it's the acc it's kind
of like clemson okay then you just
push people in the face and tell them to
shut up and sit down yeah and i
i'm gonna guess if notre dame played
clemson now i think they play in two or
three weeks
clemson's probably going to be close to
a two-touchdown favorite
yeah double-digit favorite i'm gonna
guess yeah
and notre dame had a game and then three
weeks off and
and so they're still kind of finding
themselves with new weapons but i tell
you what
their offensive line notre dame is one
of the best in the country um
and ian book has a lot of experience so
you you would hope they would make some
plays but
i also said that about the eric king in
miami that they were going to make some
plays and
brent venables and that clemson defense
just next guy up next freak up next five
star putting them in there and
they look pretty daggum good what would
your philosophy be if you're
a big ten school or a pac-12 school to
try to impress
the voters just do
just play and try to win by as much as
you can but here's the thing
we're seeing games getting canceled this
week so remember the big 10
has 10 consecutive games in a row so
is that going to happen i mean you're
not going to have i think you're not i
don't think you're going to get through
corona without having
something come up and maybe that's two
weeks of your season the pac-12 has
seven games consecutive
so listen this is a year that's it's
crazy enough as it is just play really
good football
maybe you got a chance but i don't
understand why the the expansion
conversation isn't more i get pissed
every week we talk about i'm gonna bring
it up to reese every week on game day
he's gonna ignore
me every single week but in the year of
2020 why the heck would we not expand
the playoffs
we don't know as much about the teams we
don't have as much information we didn't
have as much spring ball and
fall practice so let's let's expand it
get a few more teams in there because
now we know we got it right
and the best team's going to win but i'm
with you on that david because
especially this year where you need to
raise money you need to make money
because you have athletic departments
that have been
really decimated here and if you could
add
four more schools to this i know we
always look at the integrity of the bowl
games
well you can still have bowl games here
but if you're not going to have fans we
don't worry about filling the stadiums
of these bowl games you could still have
the fiesta bowl as part of
you know the playoff process here there
just wouldn't be fans because we were
worried about well
how many games can fans go to during
normal times
but man expanding it to at least eight
this year
i i i think this is a i think these
college athletic departments need it
it's the perfect year it's the perfect
storm um and
listen we don't we're not saying we have
to keep it that way but in a year where
everything's changing and everything's
been so crazy
why not expand it a little bit and get
more teams in there and
it makes everything yeah raise more
money more tv rights yeah
so our company won't buy more of that
yes please i mean and put it on air like
more advertising dollars like more
why is reese davis not giving you the
platform you deserve
who is reese davis rhys by god he's an
arkansas guy so he doesn't know anything
about football
reese is rhys is the man though so i and
he and by the way
he's my point guard dan so i don't get
touches unless i make sure i keep my
point guard happy so i can't
i can't i can't slam reese now he's an
arkansas guy right
he's an alabama guy yeah oh oh graduated
from university alabama
oh he did wow he probably wants a
two-team playoff every year
alabama alabama and alabama
and why did i think reese was an arc
i apologize to reese man that i
really insulted him there forgot that he
went down there you know what but back
then with reese they weren't winning so
reece didn't talk about alabama back
then
no years he didn't bring up
i never heard from reece back then nope
now
but the last 10 years i've had to hear
from him at the right time
david uh safe travels there to
tuscaloosa game day will be there
coming up this weekend great to talk to
you again thank you appreciate it
that's uh david pollock the college
gameday crew will be in tuscaloosa this
weekend
starting at 9 00 a.m eastern